fuel importers here had threatened an
open-ended strike because of a shortage
of foreign currency their customers pay
in Lebanese pounds but they need dollars
to import fuel Lebanon's central bank is
intervening it plans to provide dollars
at a fixed exchange rate
not just to importers of fuel but
importers of medicine and wheat supplies
of which have already reached
dangerously low levels
economists say Lebanon which imports at
least 80 percent of what it consumes
needs an injection of foreign cash
because Lebanon is so exposed to the
regional conflict - what's happening in
Syria what's happening in Iran the
problem between Hezbollah and the GCC
countries practically led to a decline
of the foreign investment and now the
local currency has lost value it's the
first time in two decades exchange
dealers won't speak on camera although
banks are still maintaining the official
price pegged at fifteen hundred pounds
to the dollar black market prices have
emerged how much can i sell my dollar
hundred fifty five thousand and if I
want to I cannot buy right from your
dollar fifty seven okay thank you
the central bank denies that Lebanon is
facing a dollar crisis and describes
reports of a shortage as an exaggeration
but there are attempts to limit daily
dollar withdrawals and more and more
merchants are no longer accepting local
currency they too refuse to speak on
camera is about the eight falfa to
telephone with father dollar must be
dollar for Lebanon's economic conditions
have long been precarious this is one of
the most indebted countries in the world
a decrease in deposits into the banking
sector denies the state a critical
source of Finance but there are other
reasons behind the shortage of cash in
the country US sanctions on Iran for
example affect
it's funding for its ally in Lebanon
Hezbollah which is also under sanctions
this has disrupted the flow of
remittances Gulf Arab countries also
stop providing help to a country they
believe is controlled by their rival
Iran people are starting to take to the
streets there is panic over the currency
losing value which has hurt their
spending power last month the government
declared a state of economic emergency
for these protesters however this crisis
is not new and they want those in power
to be held responsible for years of
mismanagement and corruption
XANA Hodder al Jazeera Beirut